Athena has a new problem that she's really stumped by. Her boss at the
architecture firm, left her with an important project. Working on the plans for
this awesome new building that's going to go on Grant's business property. Now,
this building is special because it's a triangular prism. That means that if we
look at the building from above, the roof is shaped like a triangle. In this
case, it's actually a right triangle. All the faces down here though, are
rectangles. Athena worked really hard to come up with an equation for the
volume of this building, depending on each of the side lengths. This one, this
one and this one. But unfortunately, she had a disaster with a cup of green tea
and the sheet of paper she was working on. Now, all that she has left on her
paper is the equation for volume in the way that she expressed the length of
one side, the height here, which she labeled 2x plus 8. Now, this expression
for volume is found by finding the area of the right triangle, that we see here
on the roof. And multiplying that by the height. Let me write that out for you.
There we go. A nice word equation for you. So, let's see if we can combine all
this information together. Given that Athena already figured out this
expression for the total volume of the building and she knows that the height
is 2x plus 8. And also, if we decide to call the area of this top triangle A,
how could you write a new equation, replacing this one in black, that only
involves the variables X and A? Just use these new expressions for volume,
height and area and put them in the proper places, as shown in this block
equation.